[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas cuando estaba a punto
de cumplirse el aniversario de la Guerra
de Ucrania se incrementan las tensiones
entre el kremlin y occidente al tiempo
que se recludecen los combates en el
este ucraniano Rusia asegura o tilda sus
operaciones militares en el este del
país como exitosas al tiempo que
advierte que lo que considera como un
apoyo directo de la otan podría llevar
el conflicto a un nivel de escalada con
consecuencias impredecibles entre tanto
tanto rusos como ucranianos siguen
muriendo todos los días en el campo de
batalla y Hunter fue al encuentro de las
familias en Duelo y también de los
soldados que combaten
nuevas tumbas que se pierden en el
Horizonte
500 soldados ucranianos que han muerto
en la guerra con Rusia han sido
enterrados aquí en el cementerio de
harkid imágenes del funeral del marido
de esta mujer vital y la fruskin un
artillero de 50 años que murió en el
frente de
su hija madre y amigos también deben
despedirse
Por qué tenemos esta guerra en el siglo
XXI no lo entiendo
Nuestros hombres están muriendo que han
hecho para merecerlo
el futuro de nuestro país está muriendo
con cada hombre muerto no puedo escribir
mis emociones es tan duro
seis soldados más fueron enterrados en
este cementerio algunos de los
fallecidos son muy jóvenes y muchos de
ellos murieron en los combates
especialmente mortíferos de baku
cada día estos Soldados del frente se
codean con la muerte el frente ruso está
a 400 metros entre esos árboles
los combatientes prefieren no hablar de
sus hermanos caídos
las emociones no tienen cabida aquí
[Música]
Esa es la guerra Claro que hay más miedo
que adrenalina pero lo más importante es
mantenerse Unidos y fuertes
[Música]
las autoridades ucranianas dicen que han
perdido alrededor de 13.000 soldados
desde que Rusia invadió
una cifra imposible de verificar este
Comandante por ejemplo se niega a decir
cuántos han muerto en su Batallón
me duele pensar en ello me produce
emociones incontrolables
me repugna y me convierte en un monstruo
hambriento de venganza
los combates se han intensificado en la
región Rusia y Ucrania se enfrentan por
cada calle de ciudades como bacmut Y
bulevard si una protestó después de que
Estados Unidos derribara un globo de su
propiedad que fue detectado sobrevolando
el espacio aéreo de la Unión Americana
mientras Beijing afirma que se trata de
un aparato de uso civil para realizar
mediciones meteorológicas Washington
asegura que se trata de un globo espía
otro similar fue detectado en los cielos
de América Latina a pesar de ser usado
por primera vez en el siglo XIX este
tipo de globos son una herramienta
requerida por las potencias mundiales
debido a sus ventajas sobre los
satélites suponen un menor tienen mayor
sustentabilidad y son prácticamente
indetectables informe de Peter Hut
Sierra los Globos se utilizaron por
primera vez para la vigilancia militar
durante Las Guerras revolucionarias
francesas en el siglo XIX Entonces por
qué china elegiría utilizar uno hoy en
día los Globos son más baratos de lanzar
que los satélites más fáciles de
recuperar y el movimiento de un satélite
está restringido a su trayectoria
orbital aunque los expertos dicen que la
menor velocidad del globo permite un
tipo diferente de vigilancia
pueden permanecer allí durante días en
realidad pueden obtener una cobertura
mejor hasta cierto punto mejor y más
amplia que la que pueden obtener sus
satélites espías y también pueden
comprobar Cómo va a reaccionar Estados
Unidos ante futuras provocaciones ante
cualquier tipo de incursiones
adicionales pueden calibrar nuestra
reparación militar
mientras que los drones están limitados
a un máximo de 18 km de altitud los
Globos pueden volar más de 20 kilómetros
de altura muy por encima del tráfico
aéreo son silenciosos de bajas Y
prácticamente indetectables los
instrumentos de vigilancia instalado
funcionan con paneles solares pueden
controlarse distancia o moverse con el
viento y utilizan nuevos algoritmos Para
aprovechar la meteorología en realidad
hay algo que es muy nuevo que es la
adición de estos algoritmos de
aprendizaje automático que pueden
ajustar la altitud del globo para captar
el viento Así es como se controla su
trayectoria Estados Unidos no es ajeno a
los globos según político el pentágono
ha gastado 3,8 millones de dólares en
proyectos con globos en los últimos dos
años y tiene asignados unos 27 millones
más para continuar con estos esfuerzos
en Perú miles de indígenas tras viajar
cientos de kilómetros protestan a diario
en la capital la represión de las
fuerzas del orden no los atemoriza y
continúan en su lucha que exige la
renuncia de la presidenta Dina boluarte
el adelanto de elecciones el cierre del
Congreso y una nueva constitución
nuestro corresponsal en Lima Francisco
Zacarías estuvo con ellos
Juan mamani dejó de cultivar el campo a
sus 60 años recorrió 982 kilómetros
desde copani su pueblo natal para
protestar no nos dejaron marchar
tranquilamente nos provocan no con
infiltrados ellos son los primeros
asesinos nosotros venimos a ser
pacíficamente nuestra lucha nuestra
lucha es justa
esta lucha tiene que ser hasta último
Hasta quemar el último cartucho Aún es
el reinicio de las protestas alrededor
de 60 peruanos han muerto y más de 1500
resultaron heridos debido a la represión
del gobierno de Dina boluarte según
denuncias de organismos de Derechos
Humanos
pese estas cifras la lucha permanece en
Lima los indígenas duermen donde pueden
y se las ingenian para alimentarse con
lo que encuentran los manifestantes han
amenazado con recrudecer la protesta
porque el congreso rechazó el adelanto
de elecciones hay intenciones de tomar
el congreso hay intenciones de tomar
instituciones públicas como fiscalía
es ministerio público poder judicial
otras instituciones más donde campea la
corrupción al no aprobar el parlamento
el adelanto electoral el descontento
social ha crecido en contra de Dina
boluarte y al oler esa debilidad lo que
van a hacer es en lugar de replegarse
van a avanzar porque se van a dar cuenta
que Dina boluarte y el congreso no tiene
ni capacidad ni intención de resolver el
problema frente a eso yo creo que las
marchas van a continuar los bloqueos van
a continuar la violencia Va a continuar
Lamentablemente y ahí lo único que le va
a quedar al gobierno será seguir
reprimiendo con el saldo lamentable que
pueda venir adelante los manifestantes
inspiran su lucha en los ancestrales
incas afirman que no se rendirán hasta
conquistar sus demandas sin importar que
en el intento quizás puedan perder sus
vidas
la contaminación de uno de los
principales ríos de Guatemala afecta
desde hace ya varios años la vida Marina
del Mar Caribe así como varias playas de
Honduras este problema ambiental podría
terminar en una demanda internacional
que enfrente a los dos países
Centroamericanos Guatemala hace
esfuerzos para que el conflicto no
prospere Pero la realidad juega en su
contra como nos cuentan nuestros
corresponsales en Centroamérica Aurora
you y Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
Guatemala no tiene Cómo esconder la
basura debajo de una alfombra unas
20.000 toneladas de desechos que
anualmente arrastra el río las vacas
aportan el 2% del plástico que llega a
los océanos del planeta
la bióloga María José Hernández lo
confirma
este río es
agua de la ciudad de Guatemala aquí
vienen a dar todos los desagües los
drenajes por eso es un agua sumamente
contaminada
peor que el plástico Hernández denuncia
que otros envases comúnmente utilizados
por los guatemaltecos son aún más
contaminantes uno de los grandes
problemas que hemos enfrentado es este
material el poliestireno como estas
bandejas vasos de un solo uso también
materiales donde vienen protegidos los
electrodomésticos como estos trozos
grandes que vienen a dar al río y no Son
reciclables
para minimizar el impacto en el río de
la basura de 3 millones de guatemaltecos
la ong biosfera GT emprendió un proyecto
ambiental donde trabaja con la población
ribereña
porque así podemos tener un poco limpio
el río quisiéramos Que volviera como
antes cuando habían mojarritas se podía
bañar se podía lavar tomar esa agua
en el último año se recuperaron 300
toneladas de residuos apenas un 1% de
toda la basura anual del río plástico
que se tritura en máquinas para darle un
nuevo uso
la basura que arrastra el río de las
vacas desemboca en el mar Caribe y
contamina las playas hondureñas un
problema ambiental que podría escalar a
un conflicto binacional si Honduras
cumple su amenaza de demandar
internacionalmente a Guatemala
queremos agradecer a moxo y al café de
la por prestarnos sus instalaciones para
la realización de este programa y a
ustedes también Muchas gracias por
seguir un nuevo episodio de
corresponsales nos damos cita la próxima
semana siga con más información en 24 y
en France 24.4
[Aplausos]